[Music]
this Sunday is the 60th annual Grammy
Awards on CBS and you know in addition
to all the music I am all about the wild
red carpet fashion Cameron and et online
senior music editor Sophie shal AC are
back in LA with more let the Matador out
of the bag I am here in the absolute
line green room with ET online senior
music editor sophie scholl AC absolute
line is the official spirit sponsor for
the 60th annual Grammy Awards were just
days away now for music's biggest night
and one of fashion's craziest nights as
well from J Lo's iconic Versace that she
wore 18 years ago and still has in her
closet to Madonna who had 56 rocked her
Giovanni Matador look the Grammy red
carpet it's all about acceptance and
daring to be yourself she's one star we
are always so excited to see hit the red
carpet is Katy Perry she is just so
unapologetically herself but listen we
cannot talk about Grammys fashion
without V hats you talking about
Pharrell's hat that had its own meme
even before the Grammys show started
that year I mean that's the thing it's a
place that really allows the artist to
be themselves and that is what Absolut
is encouraging fans to do with the open
mic project they've asked fans to submit
videos talking about the times when they
felt most accepted Rita Ora is creating
an original song based on those stories
I love it really you do your thing
you